- Every nation should
be able to set it's own
laws and it's own customs
and it's own traditions
and all of those things.
And that's going to be different
than every other country.
Now that doesn't mean that
one is necessarily worse
or one is necessarily better.
But most likely every nation
is gonna do something different
and that strong nations
first at the bottom
and then what can build a sort of
world wide system that we can all play by.
And what we've done backwards,
and this is when people
talk about globalism,
is we think that oh if
we could just be governed
by one thing first
then we can sort of set
that down to all of the individual states.
And that, I just don't buy into that idea?
(energetic music)
- Hi everybody, Michael Shermer
here talking to Dave Rubin
about his new book,
"Don't Burn This Book."
I tried to burn it last night 'cause I ran
out of firewood and it just wouldn't take.
So I don't know what the deal is here.
They got special paper or something.
- We sent you the fire
retardant copy because you're a
skeptic and I knew you'd be up to no good.
- That's right.
Sort of like polyester
suits, they don't burn.
So, well I read your whole book.
I did it on audio and
read it before we talked
before on my podcast
From the Print Edition.
So congratulations on the book.
I thought we'd just hit some of the key
points in chapter three
because to me I think
this is where the rubber meets the road.
It's one thing to say, "Well,
I'm in favor of freedom."
Everybody's in favor of
freedom if you ask them.
But what about this point,
or what about that point
is kind of where it mattered.
Now, you and I are
largely on the same page.
I think I'll channel my inner progressive
far left person I see on
cable news and just kind of
try to steelman the other side.
- Great.
- So we'll get the major
issues here in chapter three,
drugs, immigration,
foreign policy, economics,
and starting with drugs.
Well, so you fess up
having done a few yourself.
So, I guess--
- I've done most of the good ones.
- I guess somebody could
accuse you of being
in favor of the decriminalization of drugs
for personal reasons.
But of course you're
not arguing that here.
You're arguing for in
terms of personal liberty.
I guess it would apply something
like the harm principle.
As long as you're not harming
anybody what's the problem?
Well, the problem I would
guess that conservatives might
argue is it does harm people indirectly.
So let's say, you know, it
drives insurance costs up
because you personally have
to be treated medically or
whatever and the rest of us
have to pay for that through
our premiums.
Or worse, it would be
something like the broken
windows theory of crime
where a little things
that bring the neighborhood
down a little bit
drug dealers on the corner or whatever,
you know, why don't we just
let them deal drugs like the
liquor store sells liquor,
the gas station sells cigarettes.
The counter argument to
that I think would be,
well, but it brings down the neighborhood
like graffiti on walls sends a signal
to everybody this
neighborhood is not being
monitored by the police.
We don't give a crap about standards here.
Do what you want.
And that leads to petty
crimes and then that
escalates to major crimes
and before you know it
you have a run away homicide effect
like in the 70s in New York City.
So what's your response to that?
- So that's why I love you
Shermer because you went
out of your way to steelman
some of the oppositional stuff.
So, my basic feelings
about this are first off,
and I make this point, if
you're for legalized alcohol,
which pretty much every is,
then you really can't make an argument
at least against legalizing marijuana.
I mean the amount of medical problems
and most of the domestic
violence and all of the
negative things, drunk driving that come
with alcohol there's
actually no evidence that any
of those things come with marijuana.
So that's one.
And then I would expand,
but by the way I'm completely okay leaving
it to the states, which is
how we're doing it right now.
It was first medically
available in certain states
and now recreationally available,
and I'm completely fine with that.
And if you don't want it
in your state you can move
to another state.
And what the states have found actually is
that when they recreationally allowed it
not only are they not
really seeing a major
increase in marijuana usage,
well then they're also
generating tax revenue.
Colorado is probably the
best example of this.
I'm also okay generally with
legalizing some other drugs,
so like so psilocybin, magic mushrooms,
things like that.
Then where I get into
the broken windows part,
which I think is completely legit
is that when I talk
about the light touch of
government and things from
a classical or libertarian
perspective and I have a lot
of libertarians that have
been reading this already
that are kind of pissed at me.
And my friend Michael
Malice I went on his show
and we duked it out all in good spirit.
He wants to legalize everything.
My feeling is where
this is where government
has to come in and do some stuff.
First off, I don't want
to put people in jail
for doing drugs.
I simply don't want to do that.
And I think there's
better ways either through
rehabilitation and hopefully
most of that can even
be done privately, but I
would be willing to put
some public funds to
getting people off drugs.
But I don't want to just jail
people because they've made
some, let's say, rough choices,
or negative personal choices.
That being said I also admit
to doing a lot of stuff
back in the day, and should
I have been put in jail
had I been caught.
And we also know there's
socioeconomic reasons that certain
types of people will be
caught more frequently
than other types of
people and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
But what I would say in short
is you have to have some rule.
So the simple answer on this is look,
if my neighbor, if we legalized everything
and then I found out that
my neighbor was making meth
in his kitchen or it
turned into a crack den
or something like that not
only do we know that there
would be all sorts of
nefarious people coming around,
that there would be more crime,
it would be less safe
for kids to come around,
and a whole slue of things.
Now, specifically making
everything illegal or legal
doesn't necessarily take
of all of those problems.
But I, this is just one of those places
where I feel you just need
some guidelines on society.
And where I guess the rich conversation
that we could have,
and we sort of did this
when you had me on your podcast,
we could whittle this down to okay,
then what drugs exactly
are we talking about
on all of these things.
So is it marijuana and say
medicinal mushrooms and
ayahuasca, sort of the psychedelic stuff
that generally people do
when there isn't like a
hardcore addiction, and is
the hardcore addiction heroin,
meth, things like that.
Is that the line?
It's a great place to
have that back and forth,
but what I was trying to do here,
which is what I try to
do with the whole book
is just give some basic
guidelines and then let's sort of
whittle down the differences.
- Yeah, you talked about
the taxation of cigarettes
in New York City.
I had forgotten how
expensive it is to smoke
because I've never smoked.
- It's crazy in New York City, yeah.
- New York state tax on
a pack of 20 cigarettes
is $4.35.
20 cigarettes, there's people
that do that every day.
While New York City tax
$1.50 comprises $5.85
of the $14 total.
New York is now the black market capital
in the United States for
illegal cigarette sales.
So that I presume is
just to avoid the taxes.
So there's a problem with--
- Well, it's also that, you know,
if you're taxing people
on vices in a weird way
as the state you end up
needing people to have vices
to generate revenue.
And I don't like that idea
that we're gonna sort of
in a weird way need the very
people we're trying to stop
from doing these things.
Again, this is where I just
wanna get the government
out of the way as much as possible.
But I don't want a crack den next door.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Woody Allen had a funny bit about
to get divorced in New York state,
this is back in the 60s,
there had to be a cause.
So as he said, what was it,
adultery is required in
New York City by law.
- Exactly, so you have to have it.
- You have to have it yeah.
So anyway, that's kind of funny.
Yeah, so that's the
problem, well so the counter
argument to legalizing
pot say and then taxing it
is that if you drive the
taxes too high or the
regulatory bureaucracy
to set up a pot farm
and so on is so large
that people then just do
it on the sly anyway to avoid all that.
And I think there has
been some cases in Oregon
where there's a lot of
legal pot growers still
because they can't get the license,
or they don't have the
money for the license
and then all the taxes.
- Right, and all of that
I would leave up to then
hopefully some other people
come in and they find
cheaper ways to make marijuana,
or to grow marijuana or everything else.
That's where competition
I would hope would
depress some of those costs.
But again, it's not perfect.
And that's what I try to
say throughout the book.
You're dealing with these issues honestly
as opposed to sort of this
utopian idea that we can
create a perfect law for
everybody that's gonna stop
everyone from doing all
the bad things and they're
only gonna do the good things.
That's just not real.
So what I try to do is get out of people's
way as much as possible,
but then also say, we've
got to add some guard rail
so that we're not completely
going off the deep end.
- Okay, gay marriage.
This ones kind of hard for
me to steelman the other side
because, you know, I'm so in favor of it.
But we don't have to
go back very far, 2011,
both Hilary and Obama were
against it before that.
And pretty much that was the trend.
So what were their arguments?
Okay, let's see, you know
the state sanctions marriage
for a reason because the
state wants citizens to have
more babies so marriage
is sort of the foundation
for family with children.
And of course that is an ancient tradition
grounded in religion.
But the state, you know,
gives you a tax break
for being married because they want
people to be married so
they have kids and so on,
and that somehow allowing gay marriage,
then what, people can
marry their pets, you know,
or having polygamous families.
'cause if you want lots of children let
guys marry 20 women and
have tons of children.
You know, so I guess they
were making something of
a slippery slope argument
that if you allow
that then you put a crack
in the foundation of
why the state endorses
marriage in the first place.
- And then on top of that
there's just sort of the more
typically conservative
argument, which is also
bound up in religion and the bible
and a man and a women and man
should not lie with another
man, and that sort of stuff.
Which I know, certainly
know your feelings on that.
I mean we don't have to
spend too much time on this
because in many ways the ship
has sailed and the loudest
voices against gap marriage,
I mean the Christian right,
you know when you think
about the Mike Huckabees
and the Rick Santorums
they actually have completely let it go.
Now that doesn't mean they have their,
they don't have their
personal religious beliefs.
But as an issue I find that
most of the people that we know
like Ben Shapiro who has his own personal
religious belief he's taken
the libertarian approach,
which is either that the state
shouldn't be involved at all
or it shouldn't be something,
you know, I can have my
beliefs and you can have yours.
So I'm actually okay with that
and I'm thrilled that this
really is no longer an issue.
And I can just accept, and
this is where a lot of lefties
get angry at me.
But I can just accept that
some people may not be
happy with all my life choices.
It's okay, I'm happy with them.
And that's enough for me.
So I don't even think
it's really one that,
I sort of wrote it very quickly
because it was kind of like
the ship has sailed and
you know when you get wins
I think this is one of
the things that people
don't do well in politics.
When you get a win be gracious about it.
Like, I don't need to now
rail against and say oh,
all of you used to be against it and keep
clubbing over the head.
Guys, we got a win.
Let's move on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's move on to a much
harder problem I think
is immigration.
Obviously we don't want to open
the borders up to everybody,
and we don't want to close the
borders so nobody comes in.
What's the right balance?
How do you find that?
- That was a very dangerous
word you used there my friend
obviously because you know a lot of people
don't find that obvious.
I mean there's sort of the
lefty version of open borders
and sort of no nation states.
And then there's the very
strong libertarian argument
for that too.
I am completely against
both of those arguments.
That is an odd one for the
horseshoe theory, right,
because you've got the far
lefties and the libertarians
both saying just open it
up and we'll just have
one passport and you
can wonder through and
commerce and all that.
Look, I believe in strong nation states.
I believe in the American
ethos that is special,
that is different than a Canadian ethos
and is different than a Mexican ethos.
We are separate countries.
The book that I reference in the chapter,
"The Virtue of Nationalism"
by Yoram Hazony
his whole argument is that
every nation should be
able to set it's own
laws and it's own customs
and it's own traditions
and all of those things.
And that's going to be different
than every other country.
Now that doesn't mean that
one is necessarily worse,
or one is necessarily better.
But most likely every nation
is gonna do something different
and that strong nations
first at the bottom are then
what can build a sort of
world wide system that
we can all play by.
And what we've done backwards,
and this is when people
talk about globalism is we think that oh,
if we could all just be
governed by one thing first
then we can sort of set that down
to all of the individual states.
And that, I just don't buy into that idea.
I don't buy into it from
an American perspective
when I talk about the federal government.
I like things to go this way.
And so that really is the argument.
I want anything strong nation states.
I think every country from
the United States to Paraguay
has the right to set
whatever their immigration
policy is that doesn't mean
they're always going to do it
exactly justly or exactly fairly.
But one other thing that I
do reference in this portion
is that many of the things that Trump
now says about immigration,
although he says them
perhaps without the great
cadence of Barrack Obama
are the exact same
things that Barack Obama
and Bill Clinton, and Nancy
Pelosi, and Diane Finstein,
and Chuck Schumer, and
all of them have said
in the past.
So I think when you whittle
it down to the truth
most people actually
do believe in borders.
Most people, look we know we
have something like 12 million
illegal immigrants here.
I'm for pathway to citizenship.
I don't want to kick all these people out.
But we have to start figuring out a way
to talk about this honestly.
It can't just be open
borders for everybody,
or everybody else is racist.
- Yeah, I have a wall around my house
and I have a front door.
That's kind of the wall.
- Yeah, isn't that something.
- Yeah, and so the libertarian argument
that let the economy decide.
So, we're in southern California,
a lot of Mexicans come here to work.
They do great work.
They wouldn't come here
if there wasn't economic opportunity.
So why not just let the market determine.
Now, someone like a
think a Heather McDonald
or a more traditional
conservative would say,
but they're not bringing
American value with them.
So even if they're hard
working we want them
to believe in the Constitution,
the Civil Rights and things that America,
that define Americanism
versus other traditions.
That seems to be harder
to kind of articulate
or quantify in immigration policy.
- Yes.
It's absolutely harder to quantify.
I'm with them on the spirit of that.
I don't want to insult any
of these individual people
of course, but we don't know exactly,
if everyone's just coming here
for work that doesn't mean
that they share in the American ethos.
I also don't want to force
anyone to share in the
American ethos.
So I think you're right that quantifying
actually is the hard part.
And that's why I say, you
know, you can lead this.
Every administration can set their policy.
This is one of the things
that the federal government
is supposed to do.
You know what, if you don't
like Trump's policy on it
then don't vote for Trump.
Then if you get a Democrat
in that maybe has a more
liberal policy, a more open
policy and you don't like that
then vote against that guy.
That actually is the beauty of our system
because it's not that
we're setting a policy
and this is the policy
now for the next 20 years.
- Right.
Yeah, so it's always adjustable on that.
Even if you can't
quantify it there is a way
to kind of articulate it and have some
kind of reasonable policy.
You know, at the end of
the moral arch I sort of
speculate about a future,
a world without borders.
In a way we were getting
there without economic borders
because of the internet, you
know, at least the borders
were very porous and it was
easy to trade with other people.
I can imagine that continuing
where the political unit
is the city state, not the nation state.
Unfortunately since I wrote
that in 2015 we've kind of gone
the other direction of
you know nation states
gaining more power.
But I like the idea of local solutions.
The pothole out here
on my street, you know,
the federal government
I can't count on them.
I just want the local Santa Barbara people
to come up and fix my pothole.
They're the one responsible.
Kind of that localism.
- I make that same argument
literally about our messed
up exit off the 405 near my house.
I mean that's absolutely true.
By the way, one other
thing on this quickly.
Obviously I wrote this before coronavirus,
but one of the interesting
things that's popping
up right now is that
suddenly you've got all
of these lefties that are saying oh,
we should have closed the
border to China a lot sooner,
even though Trump was
actually fairly ahead on that
and they were calling
him racist for doing it.
But you know, the truth of
the matter these are the
same people that just
two weeks before that
would have been calling for
open borders and allowing
totally free back and forth all the time.
So it's one of those things that I think,
you know, you sort of said before.
When the rubber hits the road I think
people's policies start
making a little more sense
because they're important
and they impact them
rather than just at the
idea level when you can
just sort of say something
and it doesn't necessarily matter.
- Right, okay, abortion issue,
again another contentious one.
The Republicans have glommed
onto this as like one
of their key issues in the
last quarter centuries or so
and, you know, you're
pro-choice largely and so am I.
So let's just say it is
a living human being.
It may not be a legal person yet,
depends where you draw the line.
You know if a woman's in her 3rd trimester
and she's murdered it's a double homicide.
So the state does recognize
it as a person at some point.
But isn't it reasonable
to argue that there is a,
not just a quantitative difference
but a qualitative difference
the moment of conception.
So, everybody agrees a
sperm and an egg that's
not a living human being,
you've got to have both.
But the moment conception happens,
even if it's just a 16 cell blastocyst
and the moment a women gets
pregnant when she wants
to be pregnant she talk about
her baby as three weeks old.
My baby is six weeks old.
I can't wait to have my baby.
They don't talk about it
like it's a piece of medical
tissue that has to be
removed like a tumor.
They talk about it like
it's a human being.
So why is it not murder?
- So, I love that you're
steelmanning this one
of all of them.
And as you know that my
last line in this chapter
is now that you all hate me let's move on.
So I make the concession.
What you just did there
I make that concession.
Look, we can leave it to
ethicists and religious
leaders and scientists
to exactly tell us what
the moment when life really begins.
I will concede that when the sperm meets
the egg I'm willing to take
that as the beginning of life.
Now again, you can talk about
three days later and the
blastocyst and when it
attaches to the uterine wall.
And I happen to be fairly
well versed in this right now
because as you know David
and I have started the
process of having kids,
which for two guys ends
up being a lot more clinical
than maybe you'd want
it to be, or than it is
for a heterosexual couple.
But what my basic position
on this is is that
at 12 weeks, up to 12 weeks
whether you like it or not
if you live in a pluralistic
society that is not
a religious theocracy you have to give
that choice to the woman.
Now hopefully the man
who was involved too,
but at least to the woman.
I don't like it.
I don't like the idea of it.
You know, I like the phrase
it should be rare and safe
is the idea.
But then there's a lot of cascading issues
for the purely right to life crowd.
I mean first off I chatted
with a lot of right to lifers
who will tell me privately
that although they take that
hardcore no compromise
position that privately
they know if their daughter
got raped or if they
found out if their
daughter had a child with
severe brain abnormalities
that could never
live a fully actualized life
that they would do something.
Now, that's not a reason
to make abortion legal.
But I think it shows that
we all live with certain
inequities and inconsistencies
in our ideology.
So I think the best you can do,
again, if you're just
trying to create guardrails
on a society that's gonna
allow people from all
walks of life and religious
beliefs and philosophical
beliefs and everything else,
if you're just trying to
guard as many of those people
to be free then you pick
a fairly early time in the
pregnancy, which is first trimester,
and then you put a couple
caveats around that related
to the mother's health,
and then, you know, severe abnormalities
that could show up beyond that.
But I just, it's unfortunate,
and you know abortion
unfortunately has been
fetishized in a weird way
by some on the left and
all of those things.
This is the hardest ones to talk about
and I don't think that there's
an absolutely great answer.
I will just say one other thing.
I know we see largely similarly on this.
That I think in many ways
this is the one that keeps
let's say people like you from
saying you're a conservative,
and keeps conservatives from
saying people like Shermer
is a conservative, that abortion,
I've noticed this with a
lot of my sort of liberally
libertarian friends or
let's say ex lefties
that this is the one that
they go, I could never be
one of them.
And this is the one
where the conservatives
are like yeah, you can
kind of never be one of us.
Which in many ways is why
I don't call myself a conservative.
Do you think that's fair?
- Yeah, but again it's
really just in the last
couple decades that it's become such
a conservative hot button this year.
It used to be more moderate Republicans
were in favor of Roe v. Wade.
Tom Goldwater Republicans,
or Goldwater Conservatives
who was really we would
probably call a libertarian
or class neoliberal today that, you know,
Reagan never made a big deal about
abortion like current
Republicans seem to have to.
But, speaking of fetishes, you know, guns
have become fetishized on the
right almost beyond belief.
You know, we're talking
today after that group of
protesters were at the
capitol at I think Michigan.
Pictures of them online
but they're, you know,
military style assault
rifles, it's like holy crap.
They're just showing up with their guns.
It seems to be one of
these things that the
gun represents something
else like freedom, liberty,
or whatever, that other
freedom loving countries
don't seem to have.
Why is that?
- So interestingly this
is one where I think
I'm a little more
sympathetic to those people
than you are probably.
But that being said I know
that we're both proponents
of the 2nd Amendment for
sure and believe that you
should be able to defend
your family and your property
and the rest of it.
You know, in this portion I
lay out some of the things
that there are more guns at this point
we think there are more guns than people
in the United States.
There's probably something
around 350 million guns
in the United States.
And all of these ideas, buy back programs.
Well, if the government
buys back something
that implies it was the
government's to begin with.
You only buy back something
that you once owned.
So we use a lot of strange
terminology around this.
You know, we have odd
things like when I go into
my local supermarket here where it says
no firearms allowed,
and it's like well yeah,
all the good guys who
are non-murderous people
are gonna follow that.
But the guys that want
to create chaos aren't.
So we have a really this in many ways this
is sort of similar to
the abortion one where
the way we talk about this
it's almost like we're
just talking about things
from a different perspective.
So I also make a point that the gun issue
is not one of my hardcore pet issues.
But I do believe in a
case like what's happening
with Michigan right now that those people
as long as they don't break whatever the
current gun laws are in Michigan
they're allowed to protest.
If they have open carry there
then they are allowed to
protest openly, and fortunately,
at least as of our
taping of this right now
there hasn't been any incidences.
There hasn't been any violence.
When people always attack
the NRA for this stuff
it's never NRA members that are doing any
of these mass shootings.
Often it's NRA members
that are security guards
that kill the shooter.
So, I think we have to
just start thinking about
it in a more mature way.
But your question really
about why do we have this in
America, this feeling
about guns that other
countries that are western
countries don't there is a
spirit in America and
it's because of how our
nation was founded.
We were pushing back against
the king and live free or die,
and don't tread on me.
And I'm leery of doing
anything that would quash that.
So it's not, again, this
is one of those ones,
and this is what I try
to lay out consistently.
These are not perfect answers.
I think they're guideline
answers for you to inform
your own opinion.
- Yeah, social psychologist
Richard Nisbett
studied the culture of honor
particularly in the south.
His argument is that democracy
came late to southern,
western southern states
and by that the long arm
of the federal law with court systems
and police and law and
order was just not there
and people had to take on themselves.
'Cause everybody wants
fairness and justice and
the right thing to be done.
And if the police aren't gonna be there,
there's no court, I have to do it.
And that's where the gun comes in.
So, that's why gun violence
is higher in western states
and southern states, crime
rates are higher in southern
states than particularly
in New England states
where the citizens were largely disarmed
before the pile up of guns and so on.
But anyways let's just
finish up this chapter
on economic policy.
Here I guess the steelman
argument would be
isn't it obscene that say
CEOs make you know 1000 times,
10000 times the amount
that the line worker makes.
To see Michael Isner at
Disney he's not working
10000 times harder.
He's not 10000 times smarter.
Why is he getting that kind of reward?
Shouldn't we, I've even heard libertarians
like Charles Murray go
yeah that is really obscene
how much money.
The disparity is just staggering.
You know, shouldn't we curtail that a bit.
The corporations won't
do it 'cause they won't
then maybe the government
needs to do some of that.
- Yeah, so I don't really
think that's the job
of the government.
So the way I would
frame this is we're both
friends with Peter Thiel who's worth
I think probably about six billion dollars
or something insane.
He's got a sick house.
He's got several sick
houses that I've been to,
but I don't deserve any of those things.
This guys has helped create PayPal.
He created Palantir.
He's invested and taken tremendous risk
in all sorts of companies.
And by the way, tons of people
that inherit millions and
millions of dollars lose
it almost immediately.
You know, you hear all of these
stories about young people
that inherit, you know, they
have all sorts of money.
It doesn't just mean you're
gonna have it forever.
I don't know that it's
the government's job
to tell companies oh your
CEOs can't earn this much,
because then also what
happens is you end up
getting lessor quality
CEOs and people want
to figure out other things to do.
I mean, there's a reason
we don't have a lot of
great minds in government right now.
But it has something to
do with caps on salary
and the rest of it.
Look, do we have some sort
of inequity in finances
in America?
Of course we do.
I don't know that there's
really any way around it.
You know, I also, in the
economic portion of this
I talk about taxes and
I'm just a firm believer
in general we don't have
a tax problem in America,
we have a spend problem.
You know, the government
operates by every department
has to spend their
budget every year unless,
or they get their budget cut.
So they always spend it
or go over and then demand
more money.
And then everyone says,
oh we have to raise taxes.
And even right now in
the midst of corona while
we're doing this stimulus I would much
rather instead of the
government just giving
people money, which I'm not
opposed to for the people
that are hurting right now,
although I don't love the concept.
I would much rather have
allowed people to keep
much more of their money
in the first place.
So what I call for basically
is an 18, well I call
for an 18% flat tax with some exceptions.
I actually do a little
bit of a progressive game
which is where I say classical liberalism
are just guilty libertarians.
If you make something
over five million bucks,
yeah, you can pay a little bit more.
I'm not even sure it's economically sound.
And I'm pretty sure Tom Gisald would smack
me over the head with a
newspaper for saying it.
But again, I'm talking
about guidelines here,
so that's where I would
be throwing a little bit
to the lefties to say yeah,
you could pay a little bit
more up top.
And by the way at the bottom I am okay
with the poorest amongst us
getting a free ride on taxes.
But I think a flat tax
it would get rid of all
the loop holes.
It would treat us all equally.
It wouldn't punish
success and I think that's
sort of how you have to do it.
We know that this system's not working.
We know that there's a
million ways around it.
We know, Michael, we live in California.
I mean come on, our taxes,
you know how much better we'd be doing
if we live in Texas and
right now we can't even
go to the beaches.
So what the hell are we doing here.
I'm not sure.
- Well, the beaches are
still open in Santa Barbara
if you want to come up this weekend.
- Oh you're doing, all right,
I may visit you this weekend.
- Well, I think a sense on the left anyway
even when people like
Bill Gates generously
give away a lot of money
earlier on the coronavirus
pandemic that NBA star
gave a bunch of money
to the workers of the
stadium where they play,
the arena where they play.
That was in New Orleans.
But some of the pushback against that was,
yeah, but let's not praise
him too much because he
shouldn't have had that much
money in the first place
to give away.
- Yes, and then it's
suddenly like, you know,
this is what AOC does.
It's like, we're gonna tax the
hell out of the billionaires
to get what we want, and
also billionaires are evil.
And that's very much like
the cigarette thing before.
Cigarettes are evil, they're killing us.
We're also gonna tax them
to do the things we want.
This is a very dangerous play.
Its also a very dangerous
play by gates because
it's like no matter how
much you give you're
still gonna be the bad guy in their eyes.
So I don't think that that
sort of guilt ridden policy
is a great idea.
That's where I would just
rather we flatten the taxes
as much as possible with
some relief at the bottom,
a little extra up top,
which again I'm not even sure is morally
or financially right.
But that would be just throwing
something to the lefties.
And then pretty much you get
the government out of the way
and you cut back some
regulation and you let
the economy move.
- One of my arguments
against that idea is that
now there's what we see
and what we don't see.
What we see are the
billionaires that made it.
What we don't see are
thousands or tens of thousands
of entrepreneurs who never
made it or they're just
kind of barely successful or they failed,
or they lost all of their money.
I have a VC friend who tells me that,
I forget what the exact numbers are,
out of 100 pitches they find one.
And out of 100 that they
fund one makes it to IPO
where the head guy makes
a gazillion dollars.
So many are called few are chosen
and we only see the one at
the top and go hey hey hey
how come that guy gets so much money?
Well, if you're gonna take his money then
what about all the failures?
Are we gonna fund them?
In a way we are funding them
by saying you should take
all these risks because if you make it
look at what you get.
And if you lose sorry buddy.
- That is the exact point.
Listen, as a guy that just
started a tech company
in the last year I've been
in a lot of pitch meetings.
We've pitched to a lot of people.
Some people bit, some people didn't.
And if it's a bust some
people are gonna lose
some money and if it's a win and we go to
IPO one day
some people are gonna
make some serious bank
and that's what free market
capitalism is all about.
- Right.
Okay, last kind of general,
I don't think you talked about
prostitution and polygamist
marriage in the book, but
I wanted to touch on that
in the sense that the
libertarian or classical
liberal argument of the harm principle,
you know, consenting adults prostitutes
and say polygamist
women that want to marry
the guy and have sister wives or whatever,
now what's wrong with that?
Now I used, that's the
position I've always held.
But then, you know, when
you kind of pour into it
and you see kind of a lot of
these women in prostitution
were teenagers, they
weren't really consenting
and the pimps get them drug
addicted and they beat them
and, you know, so I thought,
hmm, maybe the state,
the light touch of the
state has to kind of
regulate some of that.
And also these polygamist women,
you know they were raised since the,
you know the time they
were children this is
what you're gonna do.
You're gonna marry this old guy.
Okay, what do they know?
So then when you put
them on camera they go,
"Yeah, yeah, I love being
a sister wife to so in so."
But they don't really know
what the kind of autonomy
and free choice would
be like if they weren't
raised that way.
To me this is a hard one
because it's implying
that the state's gonna
get in there and muddle
around about what it means
to have free will or consent
or autonomy.
- So this is, I don't
talk about it specifically
in the book, but I did write a little bit,
you know we had to cut some
things as you have to do.
On the prostitution side
I'm actually okay with
prostitution being legal.
I get all of the more
traditional conservative
arguments about what it does
to the women and the family and all that.
But we know it's
happening anyway and they,
you know, there are plenty
of studies out of Amsterdam
where they're in a union
and they get benefits
and all sorts of stuff
and you can clean it up
and get some of the drugs out.
So that would be one.
As for the multiple wives
I'm sort of with you.
It's a messy one and
again this is where I get
the more traditional conservative argument
about the traditional
family as sort of the
building block for everything else.
So I would lean, I would lean against it
just by saying if we're,
if the government is involved in marriage,
which it is right now then
it should just be one person
can marry one person and
we just leave it at that.
I think we should probably
put that one aside.
That's a whole other thing.
I know we've got one more here.
- Okay, final point, so
one of my favorite books
that gets pushed against me
I'm a big pro free speech
idea and tolerance, is Carl
Poppers "Open Society."
this is always thrown at me.
What about the Poppers paradox,
that is if you tolerate intolerant people
the intolerant people will
get power and they won't
tolerate you and therefore
they'll get a toehold and then take over.
What's your counter to that?
- This is almost the
hardest one there is, right.
That's why it's the paradox.
And I think we see a
lot of this these days
that there are a group of
highly intolerant people
who are telling everyone else
that they're the intolerant
people when we know that
the ones who are saying
it would gladly use the state
to silence other people.
So this is a massive problem.
I would say look right now it's like Trump
happens to be in power
and, you know, they can say
that the conservatives
and the religious people
are all intolerant, but
nobody's coming to knock
on their door.
You can tweet at Trump
all day long that he's
Hitler and all the worst
things in the world,
then the gestapo doesn't
show up at your door.
You don't get pulled to the gulag, right.
What I do fear though
is the counter to that
which is imagine if we had
a really progressive or
leftist president and
suddenly the same thoughts
were being presented,
you know, if he tweeted,
you know, let's say it was
President Elizabeth Warren
and she tweeted out something and suddenly
all of the conservative commentators
were telling her she's
Hitler and just saying
all the awful things that people say
about Trump all the
time I'm fairly certain
that the progressives would gladly use
the power of the state to silence dissent.
So I do think this is,
this is almost one of the
biggest problems that we have
right now because there's
an assymetry between,
it's not just an
assymetry of power it's an
assymetry of what type of
people want to use power.
Lefties are generally saying
we want the state to do things.
They believe the state
can do a lot of good.
The more libertarian
minded of us it's not that
we don't think the state could do good,
but we're leery that the
state could do a lot of bad,
so we don't want to give
it that kind of power.
So this is why the paradox is the paradox.
- Yeah, I also think it's
very unlikely to happen here.
It doesn't happen in
most places historically,
you know, people always
throw up Hitler and Stalin
and Mao and I guess Kim Jung Un now.
But there aren't many of
those examples historically
since the rise of democracies.
Most democracies can
tolerate some intolerance
without intolerant people
taking over the press
and so on.
As much as Trump has been
hammered for himself hammering
the New York Times for example,
the failing New York Times,
apparently The New York
Times subscription rates
are highest they've ever been
and you know they seem to
be thriving pretty well.
So whatever he's doing is
not stopping the press.
- Well that's what I always say.
It's like everyone's actually,
you may want Trump to
behave more presidential
or more professionally,
whatever that means, but he
attacks the press.
The press attacks him.
Nobody gets thrown in jail.
Nobody's being dragged
off and the rest of it.
Which reminds me of the
Colin Kaepernick thing,
which I write about.
Which is Kaepernick decided to kneel
that means so he expressed himself.
Trump is allowed to say
what he wants about it.
He can't use the
government to stop the guy
from doing anything, but
he's allowed to voice an
opinion too.
The owners of the team are allowed to say,
well this is becoming too
much of a headache or not.
And I don't want him there.
The fans are allowed to say,
well I'm gonna protest
and not buy tickets,
or I'm not gonna buy jerseys.
So ironically the whole
Kaepernick thing was
framed to the world as if free speech
was under attack, but literally everybody
from the fans to the
president of the United States
and everyone in between,
the owners, the whole thing,
everyone expressed themselves.
And nobody was dragged off.
So this is where I think it
would probably be a good ending.
It's sort of like this
is where America's done
tolerance pretty well.
And we should just be leery about throwing
the baby out with the bathwater.
- Well those were all the
right answers so I'm not
gonna burn your book after all.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of
all future videos be sure
to subscribe and click
the notification bell.